this is a production of Cornell
University
I can alright good thanks Andy good to
see you Andy McNish with us today and
we're not I'm not going to waste a lot
of time because there's lots of lively
conversation I thought I'd put something
funny up when you don't have your
professional sports turf managers on the
job this is the kind of stuff that that
can happen so hopefully we'll take
another half hour here and and distract
you for a little bit get you to think
maybe about bigger issues that are going
on try to find a little inspiration and
people that have led us through
difficult times in the past and and and
at times seems anxious I think we'll
remember we've come through as a species
a lot worse than this but I will tell
you I was chatting with some people on
our shortcut conference call this
morning and we talked about how this new
pathogen is traveling around on on
geraniums or begonias I thought it was
this morning Carl and and right away
rich Buckley says oh yeah we've got the
network set up and we're gonna isolate
and quarantine that population of
begonias and I'm thinking boy if we
could just do that with the human
population we'd be all set
so again drawing your attention to the
resources that are out there the STM a
has continued to provide those resources
very effectively across the board for
the things that you need to know locally
I'll put this on so you can see it this
is going to be what it's going to look
like for a while as we start to wander
out there for those of you that are
wandering out of New York particularly
if you're interacting with somebody
these are executive orders now it
behoves you to pay attention to these
things and certainly if you're in school
districts or municipalities or
facilities you're gonna actively be
hearing about the things that are going
to be required from you we're gonna talk
about synthetic turf in a minute but
this is multi use during kovin let's go
to our superintendents of facilities
buildings and ground survey for this
week they did a survey asking and they
got about forty five answers how many
days a week does each maintenance staff
member work now so you can see there's a
significant um
out of people who don't work a full week
that are part of maintenance staffs on
school districts across New York so
obviously this is a point of concern if
we've got fields and things to take care
of and of course for the first four
weeks we've been actively talking about
that now
Adam Tom's and and Nick Christians did a
wonderful job oh let me go I'm sorry I
got that slide in the wrong place there
Andy sorry about that here we go I'm a
little confused now I got it all right
anyway we've been talking about the
weather before we get the synthetic turf
and tell you why we're talking about
synthetic turf today let's just talk
about how the growing season has
progressed well first off back in March
it was looking pretty good as far as
growing grass grows you had temperatures
in the 60s in two inch soil temperature
in the 60s and you could see well into
the upper 50s down there in State
College where AM B is started out
looking pretty good and then the
following week you could see it really
starting to emerge in the metropolitan
New York area the soil temperature at
two inches and we had literally been in
a stall and backtracking so this was
last week and this is the soil
temperature as of just a couple of days
ago and it really hasn't moved very much
and now we're barely creeping into the
60 I'm sorry into the low fifties where
many of us are still in the 30s so from
a grass perspective obviously some of
you are growing grass actively in sports
turf because if you're expecting spring
sports you're setting your fields up in
the fall so that you're good to go when
they want to play lacrosse at the end of
February in the Hudson Valley or in
upstate New York on natural grass fields
right so so you've been gearing up that
doesn't mean the grass isn't growing
right but here's what's happened to the
growing season early on you could see it
was creeping along and then the second
week we were together you could see
double-digit accumulations we were
warming up in the early part of April
and to be honest we've been in a stall
since then and it looks like the
foreseeable future isn't going to change
in fact we heard from our Northeast
climate center person today indicating
that we're not going anywhere May
even for the next two weeks it looks
like cool temperatures and very little
growing degree days are accumulating in
fact hardly anywhere north of the
Pennsylvania New York border accumulated
a single degree day at all last week so
we're staring at this plots a
significant amount of rainfall is on the
way
that we heard in some places as much as
two and three inches of rainfall over
the next week well again what does this
mean for grown grass well this is the
same slide I found look out guys
yesterday this is the same slide I've
been using for the last several weeks
because we really have barely budged
above the 50 degree average air
temperature and again this is growth
potential the potential that your grass
has to grow based on the current
temperature now there can be other
factors that can drive this for example
if you've got a nice dark green turf
it's gonna warm up more rapidly you're
likely to get warmer soil temperatures
right so so soil temperatures and air
temperatures are going to combine to
give you some growth but in general
we're nowhere near what we would
normally be in fact the reports this
morning were that we're a week two to
behind now in spring normal springtime
temperature accumulations okay so let's
transition right away I there's not a
lot to say I mean we've talked about a
lot of things over the last several
weeks and when Carl and I first were
talking about doing webinars we were
going to do this every other week and
then it seemed like the issues we're
really you know emerging and we should
talk about it and as we've not been
growing grass and really a lot of the
things you should be doing is planning
for what you're going to be working on
moving forward many of you don't have
people using your fields but their
raises questions about synthetic turf
you so let me go back to my presentation
here again I wanted to just I didn't get
my things all together here I got
confused there I didn't save the
presentation that I created so this is
what's happening to some synthetic turf
fields they're being converted for
multiple use now a lot of us buy these
synthetic turf fields or we're told to
buy these synthetic turf fields as it's
come about over the last two decades
because it's no maintenance
it's limited maintenance and there's
been a variety of debates back and forth
between synthetic and natural grass and
I'm not going to really engage in that
debate at this stage because if you've
got synthetic turf it's there's no sense
in debating it but you you could argue
that during times like this when the
weather isn't very good and the rains
are coming synthetic turf fields provide
you an opportunity to use outside
activities without destroying the field
now Adam Tom's and Nick Christians on
the SDM a website put together an answer
a lengthy answer to this particular
question and they address in one
paragraph what you might do with
synthetic turf so first off it says
consider sweeping the fiber stand and
back up and collect any debris that may
have ended up on the fields laying down
fiber is a bit of a problem and we'll
talk with Andy about how that gets done
you know what the value of raising these
things up obviously consider have a
testing having having it tested for
safety and I also recommend maybe it's
just a good idea to sweep it off so that
organic matter doesn't impede drainage
now a hot topic around synthetic fields
are microbes and Andy was knee-deep in
this many years ago and published a
paper with Tom back in 2011 but this
continues to come up different ways of
sampling looking around for different
organisms that particular is a issue
isn't going away
so as we introduce you here Andy and we
get a chance to transition to our
conversation today a lot of people have
synthetic fields you have a wonderful
resource here with Tom at the Center for
sports surface research where you've
been doing maintenance and footwear and
safety work for a number of years you've
published papers with you know
kinesiologist all kinds of work in the
medical profession around sports
industry but the topic for today really
Andy is now that we have the synthetic
turf let's say you can't get out and
maintain or you're not going to be
playing some sports people are going to
want to get on their synthetic turf and
actually maybe if you have some work to
do you might consider maintaining it so
let's start with me shutting my
often you being able to look at me and
we'll start out right away with okay you
got a synthetic field let's assume it's
been in in the last couple of years and
you've been keeping it up let's start
with the gold standard what kinds of
things are synthetic turf managers
thinking about beyond maybe what Adam
and and Nick mentioned in that letter
well I'm not sure that there's much
beyond that I think they did a great job
you know this time of year when the
fields not being used it does give you
an opportunity to do you know sort of
the big three and that would be making
sure you're in field depths are up to
where they should be and this is a good
time to apply infill so the number one
maintenance thing for safety and
playability over time is to make sure
those in fields are up the infill is
what gives you the cushioning we have
some data that shows that higher end
fills will be beneficial on injuries to
traction I mean it's not going to make a
gigantic difference but it does make a
small difference so on our website we've
got a nice Excel spreadsheet same one
that we use in the NFL you can go in
there and and download it for free you
can enter all the data of infill how to
measure it across the field what your
target range is making sure that it's
even so that's good obviously you know
if they're not using it and the fibers
are standing up straight already
there's not really that much necessity
to broom it but if the fibers had laid
down last fall as this weather gets a
little bit warmer or on a nice sunny day
those fibers will heat up it's a good
time to stand them up and leave them
standing up so that's a good practice
sure removing the organic debris is fine
you can have a tester come in and test
the field whilst not being used which is
which is fine as well I mean I really
prefer that rather than pay a tester
five six hundred dollars each time they
come in that you have pony up four
thousand dollars and buy yourself a
clegg and then you can do it monthly
weekly however often you you think you
need to do it so the big big three the
big three infill volume and your
research was really critical right and
identifying that role in and some safety
issues right there
volume and there's tools for determining
that yep - right there are and we have
informational videos on the site so you
can buy for $15 off of Amazon a in a
insulation depth gauge
you can also buy fancier ones from turf
tech comm and Mascaro down there and you
could even use like a tire tread gauge
and you can walk around and measure
those depths for you okay so so listen
um one of the things I've always
wondered about and I've heared debates
about it and you see pictures about it
is the grooming of these fields right
obviously it's a double-edged sword on
one hand the more you sort of fuss with
them the are you necessarily you're
degrading them every time you will braid
them in some way it seems to me as I've
read you're degrading them so you don't
want to overdo it
either right in trying to stand up these
fibres
no correct and in cold weather it's
difficult especially with the
monofilament so you know the
monofilament sold as hay they stand up
straighter that are better for ball roll
that's true they're much harder to bend
over but if you do bend them over
they're a lot harder to stand back up so
you bend those over through multiple use
you know I really think that fields that
are being used every day at high schools
should probably stay with slick film but
monofilament SAR for high end soccer
fields and they do a great job there but
you have to you can't let them get bent
over you let those things get bent over
in high school and cold weather comes
you're gonna have a heck of a time ever
standing them back up again so yeah they
should be broomed I use a correct broom
the stiffness of the bristles is
important the grooming certainly does
add to to degradation of the fibers so
you don't want to overdo it but I think
that a field that's being used at a high
school you know five days a week should
be broomed at least weekly okay so what
about those times we hear a lot about
this rubber compacting over time - right
that's incorrect that's incorrect let's
hear about what I got to do if do they
compact and do I have any issues about
that they do not compact significantly I
mean if we think about why we build
natural grass fields out of saying is
that you know if we if we size that sand
all the same
it can't compact and the same sort of
thing happens with the chrome rubber and
the sand as long as it's sized correctly
and you're dealing with a good bender
it's not going to come back and that's
why it's in there so the reason they use
the tines is it's better at standing
fibers up especially ones that have
gotten buried so if you think about you
know running a broom across and if
somebody's cleat stepped and buried that
fiber it's very hard to get it out so
those times can kind of go along and
pick those fibers back up and open them
up so relieving compassion is is really
not the things that cause the field to
get hard number one
walk-off chrome rubber as it leaves we
know it gets in your washing machine is
in the hallway and it's no locker room
that cushioning is disappearing slowly
over time the other thing is paint so if
you are not scrubbing your paint
well and kind of if you just keep going
and keep painting and painting and
painting that thing will become
rock-hard so those are the two main
reasons that fields get hard over time
is there a way to top dress and feel
okay as you did done the volume research
have you learned that the volume exposes
less and less fiber that that standing
it up is easier if the volume of rubber
is is is adequate yes so it holds it up
I don't think standing and I'm not sure
it's any easier to stand up with the
higher volume but it but it keeps it
standing up it also shades it remember
them a big reason that this synthetic
turf breaks down over time is UV
degradation so if you have more and more
of that fiber hidden there's less reveal
that's what they call the amount of
fiber that's standing up and there's
good in Haitian in the field will last
long or by having the crumb rubber
filled up we also see beneficial
traction characteristics and the field
is softer so you know all of those
things combined there's really no reason
to not have that infill at a proper
height and that proper height is
determined by the manufacturer they'll
give you that target and and and so to
me what you're saying is one of the
biggest problems with these fields is
the rubber gets displaced and moved
around not that it gets compacted but it
that when you cut and you see a sprint
you know like a spray a rubber that
means it's just gotten moved from there
how do you then redistribute is it
visible to redistribute it or you have
to always top dress it no you can
redistribute it but you know it's funny
when you see all that crumb rubber fly
it's surprising how you're not getting
depth I always thought when this these
systems first came out that we'd see way
more pop marks and giving and you know
like movement of the fiber it's
surprising I mean in goal areas of
lacrosse you'll see a displacement
that's pushed out but surprisingly that
doesn't move that much and so you see
that splash you think that's a lot of
crumb rubber it's not a meter I mean
it's kind of amazing now so there's an
there there is some redistribution
needed
on you know heavy used areas like the
golden mouth of across the kickoff x4
football for some reason we always have
to be messing with but it's really just
the walk off crumb rubber it sticks to
the shoes it sticks to the uniform and
it slowly leaves kind of even across the
field over time okay so now that we're
talking about you know we sort of
managed to grooming I think pretty well
everybody just freeze for me
no can you hear me I can I can hear you
all right so let me go with this so you
don't lose me Andy let me ask you about
microbes because obviously now we live
in a new world with concern about
microbes you were way out ahead of this
early on the discussion has evolved
where are we at now at understanding how
to manage microbes in these fields so it
depends which microbes you're talking
about right and we'll start with the
ones we know something about and and can
end with the ones that we're still
pretty unsure of so bacteria like MRSA
methicillin-resistant staphylococcus
aureus MRSA is killed by sunlight and
it's not only the UV rays they're really
good at killing MRSA but the the visible
blue light will also kill Mercer so it's
not necessarily the heat originally I
thought it was because the synthetic
fields heat up but it's really the light
so you you have a field that's outdoors
there is essentially no reason to treat
that for bacteria the sunlight is a
great disinfectant we have a hard time
keeping the mersa alive for 15 minutes
outdoors much let alone overnight so
when the sun's out you've got a great
disinfectant fungi are not killed so
much by by light and so we do find when
we do a bioassay of what's growing in
synthetic turf one there's not a lot
growing and certainly not compared to
soils because it's not a hospitable
environment for microbes to be growing
in but we tend to find a predominance of
fungi mostly because they they're not so
affected by sunlight right
and then we start to look at viruses and
there's very little work done on viruses
right so there's been a few studies that
came out they show Co vid 19 is not very
susceptible to temperature changes but
there is some very early and maybe not
you know necessarily confirmed with
numerous studies some indication that it
is sensitive to sunlight to some degree
and they're also saying you know it can
live on different kinds of surfaces for
different amounts of time it seems as
though the more porous the surface is
the more it will kind of absorb the
virus and well we don't know how long
the virus necessarily lives whether
that's different in a forest material as
opposed to a smooth surface we know that
it's a lot harder to get the virus back
out of the porous surface tends to hold
on to it and it keeps it there right so
is crumb rubber and sand porous yeah we
do know that crumb rubber has some heavy
metals in it and there's some indication
that with mersa there you know certain
types of crumb rubber because you have
some cadmium in there small amounts you
have some lead in there we'll actually
there's a differential death rate of
MRSA in a closed environment without
sunlight so a new paper came out
recently about that but you're you're
talking about differences between you
know one hour and five hours or six
hours you know overnight and then
sunlight so what listen what got me
thinking about this can you hear me okay
yeah yeah what got me thinking about
this is is you know the way I think the
public connects things without all the
information number one everybody's
concerned about covert persistence on on
surfaces mmm synthetic terms had a
history of where you know whether it did
or didn't it had a history of being
associated with some microbial problems
if a sports turf manager you know as we
gear back up and people might play
Ultimate Frisbee but stay back from each
other maybe we start adapting some
sports and synthetic turf becomes
something that we use and and somebody
says listen you I want you to disinfect
this field okay don't talk to me about
just disinfect a damn field I don't want
to be worried about liability I don't
care what the research says sure great
we used to do this what do we have
recommendations or did we what's when we
figured out that it was useless we
stopped doing it
well the NFL actually banned it on
synthetic turf fields and in game day
fields because I mean they did a study
with Mount Sinai doctors and and and
this was mostly focused on mersa right
they said there is there is zero benefit
that they can determine from all the
literature for mersa and who knows why
spray it there could be a diss benefit
which I didn't know was a word until
those gawking for me this benefit is
actually a word so they so it's not
allowed to be sprayed there but now
we're revisiting that with kovat of
course so here's the thing i tweeted out
a the cdc list of things that kill Cova
there's a long list I think STM a has
put it on their website now to the CDC
link so you can look at that but one of
the things that's on there are well as
we know is soap and detergent so the
easiest and best way to me to disinfect
the field is about eight handles of of
tied right eight gallons are tied in
your spray tank spray it out across the
field run the broom over at once while
it's still damp and I know if it's too
damn you know you're gonna pick up crumb
rubber so you have to play the game as
to when the water contents right and we
know from mersa we studied it that ain't
gallons over the field is enough to kill
mersa without sunlight so what it does
to virus what the concentrations need to
be I don't know but detergents and soaps
are on the list for the CDC so with the
knowledge we have right now and it could
change right or the knowledge we have
right now about eight handles are tied
in this spray tank spray it across the
field drag it once you're good
especially was there any particular
fragrance you were fond of Andy well I'm
sort of a snuggles guy and we did find
that that fabric softeners work just as
well right I mean they are a cationic
surfactants ID as an anionic surfactant
but both of those worked it's just that
the fabric soft there's a little more
expensive but it smells nicer and we we
the only reason we use Tide was
you know it's the number one selling
brand it's not that it's brand dependent
look at the list that's that's out there
I don't think you need anything real
complicated to to do this then at least
you've made your best effort you can
tell your administration hey we did it
do the other event somebody does it
prevent an athlete during an event of
falling depositing it and somebody else
falling in that same spot and getting it
not necessarily right but I'll tell you
there is no documented case that I'm
aware of of anybody ever getting mercy
from a field what happens is they fall
they abrade themselves because synthetic
turf smore abrasive and they run up rub
up against another athlete that has has
the mersa and they get it from the other
athlete not from the field but they got
the abrasion from the field so it would
be my hopes that you know before you
start letting somebody play Ultimate
Frisbee that those people are tested and
they're co-ed free right I'm not sure I
want to play Ultimate Frisbee with
somebody who's positive right but let's
say you have to disinfect the field
eight handles of a good detergent
sprayed out across the field like
brooming and I think you're done and if
it's outdoors you don't you give it 24
48 hours and my guess is and that's a
guess at this point that the COBIT is
gone but I will know there's more
information is gonna be needed on yeah
this is a big area and again because of
that link I think we're going to get
questions that's why I'm so glad and
preciate you coming on Carl we got
questions
yeah just one question for Mike we were
talking earlier about how the compaction
issue really isn't there with the rubber
infill but he's asking about the organic
and thorough materials is that a
situation where compaction is an issue
so I have less less experience with it
what are organic infill so let's start
with that so organic infants are coconut
husks we have seen cork being used
walnut shells which I guess they're
still out there the most recent ones
that I see are things that are pine
byproducts I mean we're considering that
for a couple of fields the only field in
the NFL using that as Miami's indoor and
they have a
Jannik infill so with the organic infill
you don't get much cushioning from that
so at this point in time our
recommendation is if you're gonna use an
organic infill you want to have a pad
under it the crumb rubber or we find
that if you keep those crumb rubber
levels up you really don't need a pad
and half the fields in the NFL gameday
fields are over concrete or asphalt
without a pad they have no problem G
maxing under a hundred are the organics
heating up more Andy so they're actually
supposedly slightly cooler now they're
cooler for a couple of reasons one they
hold on to moisture but our research on
heat shows that the majority of the heat
comes from the fibers it's the fibers
reflecting astroturf without any infill
is much hotter than the infill ones
because it's all fiber a single with a
single pile carpets a single pile carpet
so the organic in Phil's have been shown
to help but they're kind of like
everything else you get 1020 degrees out
of them and that's about what you get
but so they're a little cooler and they
will hold a little bit of moisture but
usually they don't wick enough of it to
make a difference it's or like once that
top 8 of an inch of infill cools but
they don't offer a lot of cushioning so
you need a pad so this compassion matter
because we're really relying on the pad
at this point right and unless so among
the the organic infill but again my
experience and research on organic
infill is minimal compared to to crumb
rubber I hope that answered the question
it's exactly right Carl we're right at
the 30 minute hour the fastest 30
minutes I think we might be done with
the doctormick knit maybe one more quick
one I know that is asking about he wants
to know carrier volume of water when
you're putting out 8 gallons of time you
know 150 gallons okay per acre for the
whole field that's like an acre and a
half
you don't even a lot of water but it
doesn't have to be a sloppy spray you
can make it a sloppy spray if you want
but it's harder to broom when the
surface is wet and I see I see that
somebody's asking about shoes and we'd
have another 20 minute conversation with
Andy if we'd open it up to the shoes but
suffice it to say
Andy's got a 2019 shoe study that he
conducted available at the sports
surface website that he made that's true
you can find out at SSRC psu.edu and not
only do we have our shoes listed but we
have the posters that are hung up in the
NFL locker rooms as to which shoes are
good which ones are not
obviously they were tested at bio core
University of Virginia and with much
heavier players my list tends to be for
lighter players so it's more like high
school elementary school and they're not
always the same there's a lot of good
correlation there but there are some
interesting differences look at the
website SSRC psu.edu you're the man Andy
I always like seeing you and just one
more time you know when you started
doing synthetic turf twenty-something
years ago I think people are like what
the hell is it and I'm this is exactly
if we're turf grass people this is what
we're gonna all gonna be managing these
things so again big kudos to you for
keeping at it and keeping the NFL honest
and you didn't take a few slings and
arrows back then I can take it you can
grandpa and and if you'd like to hear
more about this we have podcasts that
we've done in another venue with Andy
talking about this more in depth on
frankly speaking on turf net that will
do some shameless promotion Andy thanks
so much for taking the time be safe
brother out there in Western PA always a
pleasure this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at Cornell
edu